dass ich mich Kinderzimmer
[Musik]
eigentlich immer gehört das Kind ist so
lang wie möglich bei der Ältere die war
eigentlich und dann kommt er uns seid
ihr
das war für mich
[Musik]
mit acht Jahren
und dass ich meine neue Wohnung
machen was ich wollte
ich bin mit 26 gewusstsogen später als
die meisten aber für mich ist eben ein
großer Schritt
ausziehe weil ihre tamilische Kultur
zählt man eigentlich aus wenn man
verheiratet ist egal ob man oder frau
und darum habe ich erst drei Tage
meine Eltern haben gerade akzeptiert und
ich bin mega froh wenn sie so reagiert
aber die Unsicherheit wenn es ums
ausziehen kann
in der Schweiz aufgewachsen sind aber
älter andere Kultur kennen die zum
Beispiel mit ihre treffe ich mich jetzt
sie ist 23
Jahre eigentlich
schwer damit
jedes Mami schaute mit ihrer reden
nur
ist einfach schwierig weil meine Mutter
Kultur eigentlich immer gehört das Kind
ist so lang wie möglich bei der Ältere
Liebe eigentlich verstehen
ja
also in der Familie also wirklich jede
redet was hast du mit dem Kind gemacht
wieso lohnt
unter Kontrolle und dann bestimmt wieder
schwarze Show Show in der Familie und
das ist so eine lustige Familie
redet die ganze Zeit über die andere und
meine
ich mega wichtig es ist so man hat mega
auf die anderen einige es ist wirklich
was die andere sagen
aber jetzt
oder das ist mega mega beste
aber willst du das
Zimmer ganz verschieden
[Gelächter]
auch meine Eltern warum ist das so in
einer Kultur durch
eure Kultur
so und ja Verständnis haben mirio von
der zweite Generation muss
okay
ich finde dich interessiert
also das macht
eigentlich
und dann sieht man halt überall wohnen
als Prise und alles und dann kann man
sie wie auch fragen und dann hätten wir
David noch richten was man wenn wohl
nichts Besichtigung ist
aber preislich und alles passt ja auch
voll und hat
eigentlich
voll okay
[Musik]
so ein bisschen Kontakt abbrechen
oder nicht
ja viel Glück danke
[Musik]
und
ich glaube das ist jetzt wirklich als
Mami wo so mir hat zum loslaufen und das
ist wirklich mega normal glaube ich also
ich glaube das hat alle älter aus allen
Kulturen und ich frage mich einfach
warum gibt es das aber ich Kulturen
Mini älter sind
aber es ist ja auch einen anderen
zweifamilie bin ich hallo
so schön
[Gelächter]
sehen und mir hatten also ich komme zwei
Kolleginnen
im Studium und dann haben wir per Zufall
und dann noch von der hey ich weiß dass
ich so cool
und hat gesagt
und dann Trauma oder was also meine
Mutter hat gesagt
mein Vater ist sehr hässlich geworden
sowas wieso jetzt schon nach dem Studium
[Musik]
und das ist dann schon paar Wochen
gegangen also bisschen
schlimmer geworden
und dann am Samstag wo dann
okay also es ist überhaupt nicht schlimm
sie bei mir ich glaube bei mir hat man
relativ schnell akzeptiert ich glaube
das ist irgendwie tamilische älter
halt trotzdem Hilfe und du kannst helfen
ja
dann
irgendwann
ausziehen ja auf jeden Fall vom Studium
das
ist sogar
weggezahlt worden und das hätte ich mir
vorstellen
so ein Kreis Problem muss hier irgendwie
wieder schweizerisches Gefühl es ist
klar das Kind um die 18 junge ausziehen
oder Menschen sogar erwartet dass die
gönnt und da ist es einfach du bleibst
eigentlich daheim bist du
damit aber ich heiße immer mehr
Verständnis für meine Eltern
will ich mehr Gedanken machen
und es macht alles mega Sinn wenn man
sich
sie sind Alter wie sie aufgewachsen sind
wie ihre Eltern
einfach nicht vergleichen in der Schweiz
und ich denke mal es ist
älterer Mensch
komplett neue Welt Erzieher und
ich glaube
Herausforderung verstanden
[Gelächter]
helft die vor die jungen Leute in der
Schweiz zieht im Schnitt mit 22
Zahlen vom Bundesamt für Statistik der
Vita ist 26 und bereut
sogar
[Musik]
ja ich darf Sie handgrunde
ich hoffe Sie dass ich ihnen
wird mir passieren
aber ja
typisch tschüss
[Musik]
Bild gesehen aber
so riesig
warum du noch
ja und dann einfach so wirklich
Privatsphäre wo halt meine Schnitte ist
und er hat nur mit Kollegen abgemacht
ganz kurz
fresh machen
hast du das Gefühl fast so blöd aus
südländischen Kulturen tatsächlich
schwieriger zum Ausziehen ja so auf
jeden Fall
Religionen hat vielleicht der glaube das
war vorher musste
mega groß und
so aber privat
also und dann ich habe schon mega es ist
Tabu Thema wenn man mit acht Jahren
[Musik]
also soll ich Kartoffeln machen
ja kannst du
gegangen sind und jetzt wünsche ich halt
irgendwie lustig finde oder ausziehen
zum Beispiel die Leute haben immer
zusammen gewohnt also auch wenn man
geheiratet hat in einem Haus oder mit
älteren aber warum hat man das gemacht
also es ist normal dass die Eltern mit
den meisten mit dem Jungen jüngsten Kind
seine wohnen früher war das so also dort
in Bosnien hat es keine Alters heute
gegeben
ist es bei euch auch so also mit den
Eltern also das hey ja also die
mehrgenerationen
mehrere Generationen
so natürlich in Sri Lanka sehr also
eigentlich ist es so und jetzt ist wir
in der Schweiz wird jetzt wahrscheinlich
mehrfaches Problem
es ist wirklich klar dass das Mini älter
wahrscheinlich nicht
ja und ähm passiert
über das Thema intensiver Vertreter will
es hat mir gesagt dass wir so viel
Ähnlichkeiten hat obwohl mir vor zwei
verschiedenen Kulturen sind und mir das
ja mir redet vom gleichen so und ich
merke genau
und es gibt mir so Hoffnung dass es
vielleicht bei mir wieder kultural
und tatsächlich wieder richtig
[Musik]
fragen ob es möglich ist mit ihrem Vater
noch
und miteinander
[Musik]
ist kaputt
[Gelächter]
bist du froh dass dein Vater jetzt hier
hilft ja sicherlich
[Applaus]
gesehen
hat
das war für mich ich habe das nicht zu
gerne
aber mehr traurig ja das nicht mehr ich
bin der einzige Vater und diese viele
Vater schon Familie
[Musik]
guten Morgen schon zeigen aber du gute
Nacht ich mache auch das Reis ich weiß
es meiner Kindheit weggegangen zu Hause
zum arbeiten sie wird nach Hause
gekommen ohne Probleme
das funktioniert nicht
unsere Kinder leben mit den zwei Kultur
andere europäischer Kultur dieser
Kindergarten keine Ahnung welcher Kultur
zu nehmen
das ist schwierig
hatten sie nie Angst davor was andere
sagen was andere Familien sagen dass er
wieder schon weg ist
unsere Kultur zum Beispiel wenn Sie hier
bitte alleine weg ist das die Fragen
alleine
ist schon mega cool
zum Unterbringen ja
tschüss
[Musik]
und sie unterstützt man merkt einfach er
hat sich einfach so viel Sorgen gemacht
um seine Tochter und ich finde es mega
beeindruckend
dass mir in zwei verschiedenen Kulturen
aufwachtet und das ist natürlich
schwierig ist weil für
Schweizer Kultur
ist einfach nicht Tradition wo man da
nicht weiterführt
ich merke genau dass es für mich mega
schwierig ist will einerseits wollten
wir selbstständiger sie und auf der
anderen
mit dem haderet
für mich ist zum Beispiel schwierig zum
all meine Kleider über zügler einfach
weil es aus der Sicht von der
tamilischen Kultur sich nicht richtig
anfühlt
ist es schwierig sie zum ausziehen oder
ist es ganz einfach
Kommentare und wenn ihr mehr so etwas
wünscht dann abonniere doch der Kanal